the single biggest blocker to innovation
is called the imposter syndrome
it's the feeling that you don't really
know what you're doing and it's just a
matter of time before you're found out
and exposes a fraud
[Music]
olivia fox thank you for joining my show
how are you today
it's a pleasure i'm well thank you it's
raining outside but i've got
nine chickens who are running around and
having a lot of fun
so life is good i i love that well i
have to
i have to hear a little bit about the
setting that you add in in a second but
but first
you know your background is just so
incredibly impressive
and and i'm just so in touch with so
many things that you've done
besides the fact that you're a renowned
lecturer at so many different
wonderful universities and you're the
director of innovation leadership
at startx that i had the pleasure of
visiting quite a few times
with my in my time at stanford i believe
that you have
been teaching a course at uc berkeley
business school that you actually had to
have people stand
and and guard off from students from
entering because it was overfilled
but really your your passion for
curiosity for innovation for charisma
is just incredible as well as your work
with alternative protein
so i don't even know where to get
started olivia can you tell me a little
bit about yourself and
how you do so many things sure i think
the the most interesting thing for me
these days is that i only recently like
in the last
year or two learned that turns out i've
got asperger's
which the day i discovered oh yeah so
when i heard that i was like [__] if
only i'd known this 40 years ago
because growing up in paris you've got
to understand is um
there are implicit cultures like france
where things are often not
said and your ability to understand the
subtleties is critical and then you've
got very explicit cultures like germany
and so for an aspie to grow up
not just in france but in paris is
pretty much the worst
confluence you can imagine i imagine
only japan would be worse
so anyway childhood sucked as far as my
environment went
um my father is
if you think i'm impressive my dad's not
just an authority in everything from
fluid dynamics
to particle acceleration he also reads
ancient greek speaks fluent german
i grew up with that right so it was
clear to me i was never going to
go into science because there's no way i
could step into my father's shoes
and um what i like doing though
what my dad gave me was the analytical
mind what my mom gave me was curiosity
about humans then i like taking things
apart and seeing how they work
so that's why i started with charisma
um because when i was around 18 i
decided all right i got two choices
either i exiled myself on a desert
island or
um i learned how to make this whole
human thing work
so i chose option two um i'm still
keeping option one open
but i realized that i had to figure this
out and so charisma was this magical
thing that everyone said you had or you
didn't i was like yeah right
and so i took it apart figured out how
it worked explained it the world
published a book moved on
which is why we i i'm stuck on i'm stuck
on that point i want i want charisma i
want
what is the secret sauce so i'm guessing
it's not ner it's not nature it's
nurture but how
how does it actually work listen it's
the same thing but i'll say later about
genius
uh not everyone can be bill clinton's
charisma not everyone can be albert
einstein's genius however
we all have the capacity to increase our
charisma or
genius quotient quite effectively
the only difference is like people who
are naturals like clinton
they can't explain how they do the
things they do
because they learned that through both
natural predisposition and also
usually through mimicry in their first
three four five years of life so by the
time you see them at their
full height of charisma when they're in
their 20s um it seems like it's innate
it's not
so charisma really is three pillars and
that's the one thing i'm still willing
to say
publicly is the model of charisma which
seems now to have been adopted by most
most people
presence power and warmth i'm happy to
talk a bit more about that however
please stop buying the book
it's more i'm serious it's more than 10
years
old it shouldn't be the bible in the
field someone else should have written a
better book by now
so some of the science has to be
incorrect by now it was
20 2011 when i wrote that book
probably the only one yeah so don't buy
the charisma
sorry go ahead i want to hear about the
charisma how does it actually work
dumb it down for me how does how do
those three pillars make up
for me to to have better charisma in the
in you know tomorrow and the next and
the next day
all right so you're israeli so you
probably don't have a problem with the
concept of evolution right you're okay
with that
hopefully yes okay hey you laugh but in
sessions in like the middle of idaho
when i've said that people are like no
we're not i was like oh [__] what do i
say next
so presence power and warmth really does
go back to evolutionary psychology
um it really is a way
for us to guess because that's what
humans are doing when they meet one
another
we don't have the time to check out uh
someone's bank account for example
so we infer we deduce from the signs
of their wealth same thing with
intelligence same thing with everything
else
presence why is presence important what
we want to see someone else what makes
them charismatic
is if that person knows what they what
we
want and need wants to give it to us and
has the power to do so
those are the three components that of
course
would have given us an advantage in
terms of survival
to be able to spot that in someone else
right so presence
is really simple it's is that person
aware of what i want and need
now that's the subconscious in the
conscious
all we see is is that person literally
um psychologically emotionally and
physically present
in the moment it's it sounds simple it's
not
easy so favorite exercise there is
whenever you feel yourself
wondering during a conversation focus on
your toes
just feel the physical sensation in your
toes because that forces your brain to
scan your whole body from
head to of course toe and that brings
you back physically in the moment
that's a quick yeah the long fix which
you're probably gonna hate it sorry it's
a [__]
this is the only way meditation retreats
and oh wow yeah um for reasons that
should be quite obvious
uh most of the meditation teachers in
the us are jewish
one of the reasons for that is of course
that unlike catholic i'm going to be so
politically incorrect sorry
um unlike catholicism where uh you have
to believe
the priest representative god or even
protestantism where you have to believe
the bible
go back the word in judaism the way you
impress the
rabbi is by asking a question that he
doesn't have an easy answer to right
right right so the value of questioning
the value of curiosity is
so entrenched in judaism well first of
all it's one of the reasons where
zero point two percent of the population
twenty percent of the noble prize
winners
sorry that's right um but two that's one
of the reasons there's such affinity
um jubu's are named that way for a
reason
it it really is whether it's in animal
welfare or in
uh meditation the proportion of jews is
off the charts
right and actually i do have to say at a
time though just the other day i was
talking to
a heredity jew here in israel that is
leading in the technology hub for the
hawaii jews which is you know
very absurd just to say that sentence
and even even in 2021
but what we do see is that when kharadi
orthodox jews that even have never
touched a computer in their life
they decide they want to learn how to
program at 30 years old it's that
question
it's that you know a quest for for
questioning and that curiosity
that they pick up the book they teach
themselves to code basically overnight
and they become
fantastic thinkers and learners but but
that but that's just something that i'm
learning so please go ahead
yeah there's that there's also um my uh
my co-author judah pollock who is um
i was gonna say he's obviously jewish
also but who is jewish we usually
interview he's bloody brilliant
i once asked him why is it that
we're such a ridiculous proportion of
the world prize winners of inventors etc
his theory is this one is
this encouragement of curiosity
the worshipping of knowledge which we
have in common
with um so many of my friends are either
indian jewish or both
in india you have the same worship for
knowledge
but then the other thing we have is
we've always been the outsiders for 5
000 bloody years and it's usually as an
outsider
that you see the most interesting things
right
my dad always says that the the great
discoveries
now are not going to be done within the
disciplines because those have been done
the great discoveries are yes right in
the liminal spaces the
the spaces in between fields at the
cross section
and right that's okay you know about the
the study where
um the labs that published the most were
the ones that were the furthest from the
water cooler
no i don't so that's because the people
would have to pass by the most offices
and therefore
they would encounter bump into the most
people from the most different fields
yeah and when we talk about genius
that's actually how our brain works you
genuinely have a genius engine
like i could point to it in your brain
uh composed it's a network composed of
different
components and the reason that those
labs publish the most and have the most
interesting findings is because that
physical structural like brick and
mortar setup
is the same setup by which your genius
engine works in your brain
wow ah sorry so back to charisma um
so what we're looking at is presence
being physically present in the moment
now if you're gonna [__] about a
week-long meditation retreat let me tell
you one thing
my my teacher um rabbi david cooper who
passed away recently
he um he once told me about what he'd
asked for his 60th birthday present
and it was a what's called a dark
retreat and a dark retreat you are
in a room with no outside stimuli
no light no sound no nothing
your your food is delivered by a special
shoot so not
one photon of light comes in and he said
it was really interesting about
after about two days he started getting
hallucinations and you know fields of
gold and fascinating things
and so i'm like so how long did you stay
in there and i was expecting him to tell
me
i don't know four days and he was like
oh a couple of weeks
what yes so before you [__]
about your seven-day retreat think about
the people who are spending
months or even years in silent retreats
and yes
i'm feeling really really bad right now
because i tried to do headspace and
after about 15 minutes i start
wandering off and and i i feel antsy
that i have to get back to real life so
i think i have some practice to do here
you do but that's the other thing that
every meditation teacher will tell you
is that the work of meditation
is not being able to stay present the
work of meditation is coming
back to presence every time you wander
right now eventually i'm kind of
hesitant about saying this because what
i'm about to say really [__] up my
meditation uh
journey for almost a decade i'm ready
okay don't get competitive about this
but but there are what's called janna's
um usually spelled in english j-h-a-n-a
though of course there's a translation
of pali the
language buddha so who knows what it
should be spelled as
but there are genres these different
stages that you go through in meditation
i've heard it described by people who
have
were previously drug addicts and are now
meditators as it's
like the best high you could ever get
but without the drugs except with a lot
more work
so i've experienced janna one through
three
um it's pretty wild
in general one it's just you drop below
the mind
it's like you really can almost feel the
mind it's like
waves on the surface um in
in general two and three i had moments
where i was
fusing into time there's no better way
to explain it now i didn't go further
but in general five six seven and eight
people describe systematically the same
experiences but they really sound like
they're high out of their
minds on something so
try to now that i said this try to
ignore all of this because the
the the best way to really screw up your
meditation
progression is to uh is to see it as a
linear progress which it will never be
right right
yeah right um that being said uh my
favorite retreat ever was of course
a buddhist retreat um held in a catholic
convent
led by two rabbis who don't believe in
god it was bloody fabulous
i can't even imagine it was fabulous the
one
um the one meditator i would recommend
is a dear friend
uh his name is shade meng tan he was
known as
google's jolly good fellow he set up the
search inside yourself
happiness program at google and he's got
a 15
second meditation tool
that's a great way into meditation
unbelievable okay so so my homework out
of this is
is basically to start meditating and i
think that one of the things that i've
been
struggling with and i think that i can
speak for my friends as well is we do
see it as a linear
progression right where from youth to
think that you know if we practice
something then every time we'll get one
percent better right that's how we form
the next
percent every day and now you're telling
me well okay maybe it's right for 99 of
things but not necessarily for
exactly meditation i'm sorry you're
gonna have to accept
that it won't be a linear progression
and again for someone with asperger's
it really is frustrating because i like
you know being able to see how they work
anyway that's just presence
and when you hear about like the
dialogue or even colin powell they'll
tell you that
they just had such presence it literally
just means that the ability to be
present in the moment now
for guys the other thing that you need
to realize
with male identifying people is it's not
just intellectual presence
sorry it's emotional presence
in meditation most of us
those who are comfortable with a nice
dry cognitive work of the mind we're
going to gravitate towards
insight meditation the pasta meditation
and that's great but that's a cop-out
the real tough work that people like you
and me need to do
is the awkward messy uncomfortable work
of the heart
and that's meta meditation m-e-t-t-a
loving-kindness now
met as a [__] i hate it it's really
awful that being said it's good for me
and in the same way that
you know like when i cop out on yoga i
go to the gym you see what i mean
because it's easier
mental sense it's the same way when i
when i wimp
out on meta i do vapasana but i know i'm
wimping out
because where the mind is a nice safe
you know understandable space for me the
heart's a
bloody mess but meta will change you in
a way that vipassana won't
for people like you and me olivia i i'm
learning so much
but i have to pick your brain on
innovation as well because you've held
numerous roles on innovation
and also with with stardex the the
stanford accelerator so
talk to me a little bit about how all of
this charisma geniosity innovation plays
into
leadership within you know organizations
startups as a founder as an entrepreneur
how does it all come together so
charisma is a tool
it's just like a knife a knife can be
used to hurt or to help charisma is
neither good nor bad per se
if you're going in the right direction
it'll get you faster in the wrong
direction will get you faster it's
just a language like any other
it is of course an incredibly powerful
tool and it's a bigger motivator than
anything
except money and even in many cases more
than money
steve jobs is an excellent example if
you send me an email after remind me i
actually did a decoding of jobs learning
charisma step by step from 1982 to his
death
and you can see yeah in videos you can
see him step by step
learning presence and power and warmth
you need all
three of these for charisma the only
thing that changes is what kind of
charisma you get
depending on the order in which these
three elements are present in you
so steve jobs did have warmth it's just
it wasn't directed towards people was
directed towards a vision
that's when you get visionary charisma
the
directed towards humans that's when you
get
the kind of the dialogues kind of warmth
charisma
um how that plays in innovation is that
of course charisma helps you motivate
people
and free their minds now i need to
mention one thing
the single biggest blocker to innovation
is called the imposter syndrome
it's the feeling that you don't really
know what you're doing and it's just a
matter of time before you're found out
and exposes a fraud
now it's not just that last time they
counted about 78
the adult population had experienced
this at one time or another
it's the higher up the latter of
education you go
the worse it gets interesting yeah
one of the mit deans told me decades ago
we lose more kids to the imposter
syndrome than to any
other cause now my theory is that
this is because the more you know the
more you're aware of the sum total of
knowledge and how small your own is in
comparison right
wow as a leader i never thought of it
that way
yep as a leader in a startup the one of
the biggest
the two biggest jobs you have is
destigmatizing
lifting the stigma of shame off the
experience of the imposter syndrome and
the experience of failure
so with failure you know about the five
stages of grief right you go through
denial
bargaining etc well guess what with
failure we go through the exact same
processes
you're humming along and failure happens
first step is denial
[__] this can't have happened second set
bargaining maybe if we tweak this or
that it won't have happened third step
anger whose fault is this how the [__]
can this have happened
and then you go through sadness
resignation etc
you can't skip this process
the only way to go through it
faster is to not fight it if you try to
fight the anger or the sadness you're
just gonna get stuck
so as a leader as an entrepreneur you
need to make peace with this process
when you go through failure and teach
your team
how to make peace with this process too
because only when you have fully
accepted
the anger the bargaining the sadness the
resignation will you be able to actually
do
a good porsche modem and then learn what
you need to learn
olivia i i think we need to do five more
episodes because i feel like we
don't even scratch the iceberg and it
annoys me it really really annoys me and
because i i have to stick to the format
which is 20 minutes long and
when it went by way too fast so so
olivia thank you for sharing with me
your insight i i have much more interest
that i need to take out of you but we'll
do that another time
but for now i i need your three words
that you would use to describe yourself
yeah um i'd say passionate is probably
the number one
and the number two would probably be
analytical um and the number three
now that i understand it and it is such
a part of me and my god i wish i'd known
this when i was
born was aspergers loudly and proudly
seriously if i had known what it was it
would have made my life so much easier
and i could have taken advantage of all
the facets of asperger's that are a
real asset so there you go olivia
thank you for the inspiration best of
luck with the new book the genius smith
i know that you're on sabbatical writing
it's i truly appreciate you taking the
time to do this with me
and i can't wait to read that and the
other books and share this with
everybody because it was just
fascinating thank you
my pleasure talk to you soon take care
bye-bye
you